let's see we can go ahead daniel we can
yes okay so um
and we are um
um this is a uh it's going to turn into
a bulletin that
um uh as one of our sort of physics
project bulletins the theory of these
bulletins was supposed to be
they're quick they're short but they're
turning out to be
uh definitely not short and not quite so
quick
okay but so this is a bulletin about
multi-way systems based on numbers
and the idea so first question can
people i have a big screen
and i'm assuming people can see things
at this resolution if they can't i can
make it bigger
it's convenient if it's at this
resolution but people should just
complain
i'm on a 10 year old laptop it looks
fine to me
okay all right if ed can see then
then it's all good um
okay so
um let me just review what what this is
and so multi-way system everybody
kind of knows here what multi-way
systems are about
the idea is to look at multi-way systems
that
are in which and i i did this i had a
little comment about this in nks
and in fact one of the more interesting
such systems i actually had
discovered in nks um
and uh let's see if i go
here say 0 four
um so i just wanna make sure that
everybody
understands what these things are before
we keep going or this is going to get
very silly
um okay so um and actually we we
one of the things that i had asked for
and i one realized i'm not sure if it's
been produced
is a modification to
um okay so let me just explain what this
is
right so at every step
n like zero can go to m plus two goes to
n plus two and n plus three
okay makes sense so three goes to five
and also goes to
sex there okay sometimes they merge
often usually they branch
and uh um
okay i'm everybody's on mute but but you
you can
please speak up if you have something to
say or or or
or um uh whatever or it's going to be
very um
um okay so let me see so we had
a new function repository
item that um
let me just see where it is multi-way
function system which i think was a
i thought it was called multi-oh i
spelled it wrong
um
i still spelled it wrong although i have
to say that this should
support spell checking better okay
so let's look at this here
um let me just use the rules that i had
got up here
that arrow thing is a nice version of a
notation for our function
object okay so let's do this zero
four let me get rid of that
and hopefully this is going to be
okay that looks more beautiful the one
thing that it isn't doing right now
which i had
thought it was going to do and maybe um
who's who's on here who could text
uh jessica and ask whether this was done
um i'd ask that there'd be a way to
label these
edges to say which rule was applied
maybe we could find out danielle are you
able to do that
yep i was just getting a screenshot so i
could point to it
okay um
boy okay all right so
but people understand okay so let me let
me go through what i was actually doing
here
and um uh i should probably actually use
this
this version because it looks nicer
there
you know i i will say that this is um
let's see what that looks like
okay fair enough
um yeah all right
anyway so i will replace those and do
course
all right so
there are questions about how things
work and i let's go to something
exciting to begin with
um let's see i was
just starting to look at so these are
these are different cases so this
is if you do n goes to 2n and plus 1
um this let's actually make that with
our
new version here um
let's say
um
see well that looks reasonable
oh great that's
disappointing
well that looks terrible
what did that just do oh i see
oh i wonder what i did wrong here
[Music]
um
thank you that no
states our state's graph structure
much better and now i want the layered
dagger of digraph embedding
[Music]
okay it looks quite beautiful okay so
this is this is a slightly more
complicated
case where we are mixing addition
and multiplication um but
what i wanted to look at uh okay great
again we got some housekeeping to do of
updating the graphics
um
um let's take a look here
so ed by the way i think you had looked
at this this case here hadn't you
and yes something else about that
no i didn't okay
okay um
okay well i think it's basically
of colot's variance
right um
so this does
that's weird okay that's an attempt
to i need to explain what's going on
here but um
[Music]
well let's see well let's go to
something more exciting to begin with
um before you get started i got a
response from jessica
she said it's not done yet um jan looked
at it but said he needs jonathan for it
and you have jonathan hostage at summer
school
oh my gosh that's not good that means i
get to do it myself
that's not good a good answer no he
doesn't need if he needs jonathan
jonathan can just do it okay i'll i'll
let him out
i think he needs to actually do it
okay so again
um where should we start here
i'm just trying to figure out where to
where to get started on this
um let's do let's do let's look at
complex numbers
that's a good case okay so remember what
we're trying to do
is we've got uh
a um we got some rule
and that rule is
oh great
um
what why didn't that work
oh oh i see what's wrong sorry
okay so let's take a look at what this
is
oh there's another problem here okay
um i'm not uh
okay
actually i looked at this um
with some
[Music]
kids some of whom might be on here
because i invited them
um last weekend let me take a look at
what i had figured out
there uh see this is this is a
never do your homework on your own if
you can do it with other people
um theory hold on let me just find what
i've done there
um
um see this was
june 21st
okay oh yeah we were looking at powers
as well
we started looking maybe at the complex
number case yes
okay there's several different things
here sorry this is rather disjointed and
i'm i'm
i'm um um
yeah that was interesting
okay
yeah a bunch of different cases here i
was going to look at
ah we could look at complex numbers
first and then we want to come back to
some other things
okay so let's look at complex numbers so
this was looking at
let's take this case here so what's
interesting here
is that
if we
so we're looking at n plus 1 n minus i
let's look at n plus 1 and plus i
um then what should happen is yes we're
going to get something like this so
let's do this and say here
vertex labels so this is essentially a
coordinate grid
um placed automatic
center
oh um
maybe i don't want that i just want
automatic
okay so oh gosh it's upside down
okay so it's it's um uh okay so
the whole point is here one let's start
off from zero
um
um
um okay so we're starting off from zero
so this goes this is basically
uh making the standard you know
if we took got rid of the vertex
coordinates here
this thing would look like our other
trees
make sense but in this case because we
have complex numbers we can actually
we can actually associate this with
particular coordinate positions
that make sense to people somebody's got
to respond
at least ed if nobody else at least
ed can convince that makes sense to me
okay all right okay so
so okay so we're you know with these
complex numbers just grows that kind of
tree
so the question is and and we have
okay so let's let's try looking at what
happens
when we use um if we
so this was a case one plus i n plus one
okay so um so that's
that's when we so in general we can have
a times n plus b
c times n plus d and the question is
what will that do and i suspect
that in some limit that that is like
uh the world of of i forget fouxing
groups or some such other thing
maybe somebody knows um and and what
that will segue into
is the story of um i think i had put
that someplace here
um the story of uh
um of complex numbers where
we are looking at so so in this case
let's take a look at this and let's
compare these okay so this is a case
where we're taking
at every step um
we are this is kind of messy right
because this is
this is um taking the complex numbers
and i think there's a mapping that's
similar to the previous one we just used
that makes one of these standard kind of
branching tree things i had a bunch of
these in nks
that were um
i think this is probably an example well
this is an example that
shows as a with with non-integer complex
numbers
shows the location shows what happens
right and we we the first one thing we
would like to do
is to compare what we get for this and
one one person
um uh yes somebody is sending me a chat
ed is sending me a chat message with
what is this now
um
what is this ed that puts things at
their complex coordinates
i just had that i mean above
okay um but yes that's that's
um yes that's that's useful but now
the question is this thing that makes a
tree okay so
for example um
uh let's see where is um
this is uh uh bernat former summer
school student
and now a person working on a
project with us but he's done a lot of
work on these trees
um on the on the case of um
so he has looked at this and i want it
would like to connect what i'm trying to
do
with what he's done and this is also
related to what was in the nks book
so in the nks book uh bizarrely in the
section
on plant growth i had a whole discussion
about these kinds of trees
okay and in particular so so
why do we care one thing that happens
with these trees
is there's a question of do their
branches
uh uh rejoin or not do they have some
kind of causal invariance
in particular what's interesting with
these trees is that
these are real number i mean these are
complex number continuous complex number
results and the whole idea of causal
invariance and the whole idea of the
remerging of branches
i'm trying to understand what the kind
of continuum
version of a multi-way system is see an
ordinary multi-wave system right
when we when we're doing something like
this we know that these
the five branch and the four branch they
actually both go to seven
but if these were real numbers chances
are
they wouldn't you know go to the exact
same value
except in some limit if that makes sense
to people
so um
uh anyway so so my question
for ed or anybody else so the way these
trees work so ed do you understand how
these trees work
uh yes okay so then i want to know the
answer to the following question
what um
uh
how do i get using this kind of
multi-way system set up how do i get
something analogous to those trees
do you see what i'm saying so in other
words what is the function that
corresponds to one of those trees what's
the multi-wave function
that corresponds to one of those trees
right i'll think on that
some sort of multiplication by a smaller
value one thing you see with these
complex numbers is because they're so
low
it doesn't grow very fast if we used
even smaller numbers
the actual coordinates would go to
that sort of tree growth i believe okay
well let's let's just try that
something smaller than one
let me just store this in the right
place
okay so your claim is that if i look at
this so let's
let's define this as um let's just call
this
uh let's define it as just complex
multi-way
and um i don't know do we want to um
uh ah this seems relevant okay hold on
um complex multi-way so let's just
define
um a b
let's just make this pair a b
c d
and we want to go a net which we'll
take by default to be zero and
t and integer
oops to your literature
um okay let me just fill this in
a n plus b
c n plus d
um annette and
t
now you know what i want to do there um
i want to put up an options i'm going to
be lazy and just do that
um
okay so now we say complex multi-way so
ed
you have a speculation here that if we
use
a number something less than one here
is that right
add yes
so what it what are you suggesting oh
point point yeah point nine and
point eight for the second point nine
what should what should b
be uh point one i
okay and 0.8.2 i
okay and um let's say
zero um let's say four steps
okay that didn't work
so those are all why is that is that
because that's all
real parts i mean is this turning with
one instead
oh wait a minute that looks more
promising
um
and you think we should start with one
yeah i think we can fix that yeah i
think by by starting with zero there
oh gosh why are those points so big why
is that so crazy big um
i don't know why those points are so big
um
okay so now the claim is
why are those points so big that's just
crazy oh because we're staying
close to zero
oh okay well let's say vertex size
arrow zero what would happen then
and we have giant arrows brilliant
well okay fine let's okay so maybe what
we should do here
why are we staying close to zero go
ahead did you see the
chat from nick with the resource
function code
yeah let me look at that i think that
resource function code
is actually um
okay what do we do to plot that
endpoints
that's some so that's just looking at
um
that doesn't look promising why did that
go wrong that that
um oh gosh we need point
size there plot style
okay 0.05 okay let's try
like seven steps okay fine so that is
giving us
that's the same type of idea but that's
giving us the end points here
so here let's look i mean for example
let's look at the
map that we have in the nks book which
gives us
this is a complex this is uh
one and then we've got a complex number
in its conjugate there i think
so let's say we go to um
i'm gonna guess that might be 1.5
and then 0.5 i
and then there 1.5
minus 0.5 i right one thing to consider
is the basically
keeping with points that are within
mandelbrot's limit
what the heck happened there
that's crazy okay so what what are you
suggesting
basically uh values over two are risky
because they'll explode but things
under two this is clearly
okay we got it we gotta
figure out something about that this
isn't right because this is
this is multiplying by
let's try to understand what the
um this is again crazy
okay let's just try to understand what
this is doing relative to what this is
doing
okay so in this case implementation of
the branching model
so this is saying outer times of one
plus hash
sign
okay extend from the point we'll take
the original stem to extend from the
point minus one to zero
okay rule is then specified by a list of
complex numbers corresponding to the
positions of the tip
so this is taking it every step
a multiplication of one plus hash sign
hash sign
is the current set of numbers
one plus the current set of numbers
times the new numbers right
that makes sense yes one of those so
that means it's one plus
that one plus z where z
is the current thing times
um and that number there's a pair of
numbers there which is
some some number and we can call it c
and c
c star right
that make sense no
yes maybe okay
do you understand what i'm saying
anybody
i'm i'm trying to type something okay
okay okay well
okay if anybody else wants to respond
please please just speak up
yeah and if anyone's having a hard time
unmuting themselves because of the way
this is set up
um if you have a raise your hand
function i'll see that and i'll unmute
you
sorry
because right okay so one thing we're
trying to do is solve the question
of how do we get these complex number
trees there but another thing we can
look at
is just looking at this complex
multi-way thing
and let's just look at for the integer
case let's just see what happens
if we just compute it
for well now we've we've got a big range
of things to look at here so we could we
could say
let's look at a b
um we'd really like to look at
a whole grid of of possibilities let's
go from -1
this terrible feeling i've already
looked at this from -1
to 1 so let's say
for each of these numbers abcd
we can make them range
over um
i mean we could we could make we could
take some examples here we could take
minus 1 1 i minus i
1 plus i 1 minus i let's say
okay so for each of these
we can
i hope this isn't going to look too
stupid i mean this is going to
um
okay so let's do this let's say outer
that
and we're going to go this is better
than an efficient way to do it one
two three four level one
and then i want to label this
with probably that quantity there am i
doing this right
i know we have plenty of experts here so
just tell me if i'm doing this right
what we probably want to do
well i should have probably done this in
parallel across a bunch of machines
this is going to be too slow no okay
there we go
all right so this is our map of some of
the behaviors we can get
okay somewhat complicated now i don't
know whether these
are so this is
this complex multi-way thing where i'm
using the vertex coordinates
from i'm actually using the correct
complex number of vertex coordinates
so something like this maybe we can try
running it
um
i'll tell you what why don't i do this
why don't i
say rather than this
i think we had more okay so we got
quite a range of different kinds of
things that can happen here
we could pick some particular examples
and try and look at them in more detail
i mean the goal is to try to see i mean
some of the structure may be confusing
because it may be because just because i
mean
looks like some of these things have a
grid and then they have some other
behavior
so for instance let's take that one um
um
okay so if we go let's say go 10 steps
okay well that's a lovely looking object
um let's say instead of this complex
multi-way thing let's have a version of
that
that let's just call it
complex multi-way zero or something
which doesn't have the vertex
coordinates piece
and let's see what happens if we do that
i mean okay again i i probably didn't
motivate this very well maybe i should
try to do that
um
okay isn't that interesting so that
looks very much like what we were
getting
some of these other places up here
but now
because we have these coordinates we're
able to to see how this is laid out
in actual complex number space so this
thing
so i wonder whether we can um
maybe we should take a more minimal
example anybody got an idea for a more
minimal example of this
i could probably look at the map here um
i'd say just a random case with more
random complex numbers i sent uh
something in chat
i don't think it's a good idea because
as soon as we have
as soon as we have non integers
we will not be able to we will not get
okay we can try that but you know this
thing here notice that this thing here
has a lot of uh things that rejoin
right so if i were to do this if i were
to take this thing
and i would just say let's say seven
steps
or something and i would just say a
layered graph plot
okay what we see hopefully is that
many many pieces well it's not it's not
as convincing as it might be but but
let's try like eight steps or something
nine steps
okay so what we're seeing is some things
are
rejoining right
uh you can also do that with ultra break
numbers if
like square root of two if they're
simplified i'm not sure if they'll
collapse if they're not
no they won't if they're not but yeah i
agree with you i mean if we
if we do the same i mean anything
you know this is some property of some
number field somewhere
that allows this to happen so you know
one of the things that we would like to
be able to figure out is when is that
causal variance when it's not okay let
me try and motivate this a little bit
better
okay so let me tell you what got me into
looking at
multi-way systems based on numbers the
question is
what is the continuum limit of a
multi-way system
why do we care we care because in the
actual universe the multi-way system
that we're dealing with might have 100
to 120
branches that's a lot of branches that's
enough branches that
one would like continuum description of
it so the question is what kind of
object or space is the continuum analog
of a multi-way system
and there's and and so what i was
thinking about was these complex trees
as a possible example of a continuum uh
limit of a multi-way system and
the problem is one of the most important
properties of multi-way systems is
causal invariance
and it was unclear to me how causal and
variance would work
in the case where one has actually i'm
going to ask a question because i
noticed that phil was on here so i'm
gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna pick on somebody i
in the in the world of binomial trees
and people doing
uh simulations of of things like that
are they anything like this or is that a
completely different story
it was hard to hear
oh yes um oh okay
this is mac and i could just make one
comment on that from quant finance
the trees are much less complex than
yours because it's just a binary
decision the stock
at its simplest level the stock is at
zero today or one today
say it's going to go up or it's going to
go down so your trees can go out day
after day after day
but the changes as perceived in these
very simple models are just
up down or sideways really so what
you're saying is those
those trees are just basically a thing
that looks like this
they're very neat and organized like
your lower the third one there yes
exactly
yeah okay all right so there's a real
problem in quant finance with jumps and
we could get into that sometime but
that's a
that's where it goes all right fair
enough but so so when people talk about
evaluating a binomial tree
the the um the only they're literally
just thinking about it like
pascal's triangle so to speak it's it's
not um
there's there's nothing more complex
that um
uh so it's nothing like these fair
enough
um just thought i would ask um
uh okay local volatility full cells
could change but that's about it
all right so it goes okay i mean
always always try to leverage some other
area
if one can um okay
so so anyway so the point the question
here was
when we look at you know let's take a
look at some of these things up here
like the case of like this case here
right what's the continuum limit of this
object here
what's the limit of that object as as
a number of steps goes to infinity i
suspect in that particular case
it's a hyperbolic space um
so i don't know we can do you know 16
steps or something
um and uh one thing we could do
so this this has the property if we
start at the center here
um the number of things that we reach
going out t
steps rises like fibonacci of t actually
a good question here which i don't know
the answer to which we should answer
is if we don't take actually here's is a
good question
so if we take this and we don't start at
the origin we start somewhere else
is this always sort of an exponentially
growing space from every point
so what we would like to do is to say
i think we have a resource function
called graph neighborhood volumes if i'm
not mistaken
um
so what that's going to do is it's going
to take um
from every point it's going to work out
oh look it's using all my parallel
machines that's nice of it
uh it's what it's going to do is it's
going to start from every point here and
it's going to grow this kind of jdc ball
around that point asking how many
distinct points can you reach
by going n steps out from that point
oh blaffle look at that you see i have a
hundred
cpus in my house and
it is unbelievable how often some random
cpu will not come to life
okay there we go all right so these are
the results so this says for every node
this says the growth rate so what we can
do here i think i can do
um uh if i say something like
resource function of
ragged mean i think that will give us
a values of first of
values of this
if i'm not mistaken
oh oh right rugged mean around
argument that is not oh
oh well okay let's try um
sorry what i'm trying to do is to
average these
ah okay this is something very useful
just got posted on the chat
um i think i need to look at
documentation for ragged mean around
oh okay
what did i do wrong here oh
i just need to say that okay
hopefully i'm gonna get this in a moment
there we go
okay so what this is showing
is oh that's really weird so that's
showing
the for
this object okay so what that what
that's looking at
is given this object starting from
different points
in the object how many does how how
what is the growth rate so this looks
like
it is behaving like a
one-dimensional object here because it's
only rising the number of things that
you reach
going a distance r is only rising
linearly
which is really weird so i think the
thing we want to try
is to do the same thing for
um let's try doing it for like 14 steps
or something
and let's say
um so this is now going to
generate okay great
okay this is definitely odd and not what
i would expected because
because i would have expected that this
this looks to me like
a um uh
you know some kind of hyperbolic space
where
it has an exponential number because if
you start from the center
the number of um
nodes you reach goes up like fibonacci
of t
um but apparently
that is not the case for um
uh if you start from other points there
which is really surprising to me
um and i guess what we should
do here is to look at
um log differences because that gives us
a way of estimating
um the dimension
ah this percent 61.
okay
okay not what i would have expected at
all so this
shows that there is in terms of the
uh this is showing us the growth rate
in the number of um uh
in the number of nodes you reach so if
this had been a tree
like let's consider the case um
2n 2n plus 1 if i were to do 2n
2n plus 1 let's try that case
let's not go as many steps let's say 12
steps 2n
2n plus 1 i claim that as a tree
and now if we do the same computation
again
uh let's do this so let's say let's put
all of these together
um let's do this
and then let's say log differences
oh i could have done that actually um
and then i'm going to do this line plot
of that
of differences of this this line plot
okay so that if we look at this this
is growing exponentially because we can
see the effective dimension which is
what this is plotting
just grows like that unlike this case
where the effect of dimension
seems to go to one which is not really
what i had expected
um so in other words if we were growing
this
like a so for example in this case this
is 2n plus 1
three n plus two
as let's try that one
three n plus one
two n plus two
that's odd did i get this one two n oh
wait a minute two n plus one
three n plus two two n plus one three
and
plus two
aha okay so look at that one that one
is asymptotically going to two so if we
run it for a few more steps
let's say 14 steps here
okay so this is kind of interesting
because it's similar to what we've seen
elsewhere that this is okay so this is
like a two-dimensional space
this is making an exponential
dimensional space this to my surprise
after an initial transient
is effectively making a one-dimensional
space
um now i assume so these so
so somewhat surprisingly um
we're getting we're getting very
different things there
um and now
okay all right let me try this code that
nick
put in the um
uh in the chat here so
this was
a nested branching graph okay
so the the idea here i guess is this
is analogous to the code that was in nks
so nested branching off
okay all right now can we turn that into
so my question is how do we relate that
to this just pure nest graph thing that
we were doing what is the function that
corresponds to this
so what this is showing
somewhat to my surprise is that there is
convergence between
different different um
different orders here different paths
through the multi-way graph are winding
up at the same state
which i have to say surprises me because
i would have
expected that with oh
well maybe that's just an algebraic fact
maybe maybe it's because of the
construction of this which we don't if
we knew what the function was it would
help a lot
um so
okay so let's go back up here because
what we were discovering here
is that um again you know a question
would be what is the
large-scale limit of this object to what
extent
and for example is there causal
invariance in this object
and we can actually test that because we
could actually say
in here um
[Music]
our multi-way uh
that multi-wave function system thing
actually has a causal variance tester
um in it so for example we could test
let's let's just give an example here
and this is getting to be a really messy
notebook which i'm not happy about
um
so multi-way function system
and we're saying um the rule
is n function goes to
and let's say we are looking at that um
that one that gave the fibonacci stuff
up there two n and n plus one
starting with zero and let's go
three steps and let's say causal
invariant q
oops
okay so that one is claimed to be causal
invariant so let's go five steps check
it again it's causal invariant so that
means
remember causal invariance means every
time it branches it merges again
okay so for example we can look at this
one here and we can ask whether
it's true of this one as well and this
one
we've got abcd there so the actual
function
is um
uh let's see we've got a is that
plus b is this
and then we've got n
plus one minus one plus i
okay so let's see what this says about
causal variance okay so that says
at least at five steps that is not
causal invariant so that means that
in that case there isn't as much merging
as branching we can just try i'm just
curious whether
different numbers of steps it's still
false
okay let's try six steps
still false so what this is asking is we
go up i mean in general it's undecidable
whether you know there's no upper bound
on how far we have to test
but this is asking if we allow it to go
more steps
will the thing eventually converge or
not and this is saying it doesn't
eventually converge so this is not
this in this case for that set of brown
values it's not causal variant
what i'm guessing is that in some sense
in the real number case
there will be domains where it's causing
variant and domains where it's not
and i think that would be interesting to
see um and what we are
seeing in um uh
let's see and bernat's work and also he
had a better version of what i had in
the uncares book
where he's looking at um
this is questions about whether the tips
rejoin or not
so and again uh please
ask questions if you guys want to know
what's going on so the the issue is
he's got these trees and the question is
does you know the treat different tree
branches
correspond to taking different values
in taking different branches because
he's got pairs of complex numbers
and he's going uh you know one branch
takes
like he's labeling the complex numbers
one i i'm guessing that
you know one and two here and so he's
saying that one one one one
followed by two recurring is the same as
two one one two recurring
this make sense to people so the whole
point is that that in this case
he's looking at the infinite limit of
taking the two branch at every step so a
bunch of one branches and then
the two branch thereafter and that
infinite limit
is the same as taking the two branch one
one and then the two branch thereafter
does that make sense so unlike what
we're doing here
where we're taking we've got integers
and we're taking only a finite number of
branches
he's got complex numbers continuous
complex numbers and he's taking an
infinite number of branches
okay but but the issue is that you can
probably still define a notion of causal
variance for that infinite number of
branches and that gives us some idea of
what the um
uh
um what what the continuum limit for
these multi-way systems is
so um let's see we had another
suggestion from rick yeah i understand
that
that that resource function was made
quite recently and i think it was just
made from that nks code
um the the question that i'm asking is
how does it relate
to what we were doing before which is to
just use nest graph
right so down here if i wanted to where
is it
um instead of using
whatever i had it here i could literally
be saying
right i could be just saying nest graph
of this
okay and the question is what function
can i be just nest graphing to
get the same result okay so that's
giving
the result that i was showing above here
right that was a different number of
steps so if i go to 10 steps
i'll get the same result there
so the question that i'm asking is in
the case of these trees
with a particular value of b what is the
precise analog
of just saying the value n gets mapped
to some pair of values
what are those precise pair of values
that's the question
okay and and what i'm trying to do
um look i'm i'm going to partly because
people aren't saying things i really
wish you guys would speak up i'm i'm
happy to hear from anybody here um what
i was going to do
was trying to systematically look
um at
what happens okay i'm gonna i'm gonna
just
do what i was going to do so i'm going
to i'm afraid pretend you guys are not
here because
i'm not hearing anything so it's very
difficult for me to
do anything else what i was going to do
was i was looking first of all
at um integer
um one of the questions was
under what circumstances do integer
versions of this
where you're just adding integers when
do they
um when do they join
and when do they not join so um
uh
the um so i looked at
the case of just um
uh adding integers here
and it is the case that for any
pair of integers
um
oh actually wait a minute this is a
better case
yeah actually i'm sorry this is the case
i'm looking here
at at not pure multiplication
multiplication and addition together
okay so the question is what which
what do i get here do i get
um
and what i was looking at here uh
let's see well let me just i'm gonna add
to myself
for myself here ah i was trying to keep
this organized
um uh
the um um
dear dear this is what i get for leaving
this from
sunday until now because i've forgotten
how
okay okay let's say
um
okay i'm gonna make a section here
called
um
i'm trying to remember what what i'd
done here so
oh that's the yes okay so this is the
causal invariance case
um
well i'm going to do this at least
approximately here and then we'll do it
more
exactly so i'm going to say um
i'm not exactly sure what this is going
to end up being criteria for causal and
variance but i don't think that's quite
right
and what i'm looking at here is if you
look at this
this is asking
what is this doing what on earth is this
doing
this isn't right okay i'm sorry let's
look at this case here
this is asking um given a particular one
of these systems
a b c here we're asking
if we look at this mod c
um
let's take a look at what we need to
look at here
all right what does this mean this
is asking given a particular initial
condition
can we ever reach um okay so one way
to determine what values
we can reach is
to look at all numbers
mod k um
okay so let's let's just to keep this co
consistent let's call that k
um and so what this is now doing
um so then what we should write out here
so that we understand what we're doing
is we should write
let's just write that um
okay so i'm going to go to value let's
say three here just so we see what's
happening
and then we'll do it for the more real
case
ah stupid sorry i want that mod
k and that also mod k
okay so what this is showing is
if n goes to
i wish i put the mod outside the whole
thing i want to put that
mod i'm going to do something very hacky
here
and i'm going to put a hold form in
there just so that it doesn't
wow that's wild
okay somebody give me a better way to do
this
um
let's do this
okay all right so this is showing us
this
says if n goes to and i want to make
this smaller because i don't want
so um
okay so if n goes to
n one plus n mod one mod one is rather
uninteresting
let's get rid of mod 1 because i don't
think mod 1 is going to show us anything
let's say mod well let's say mod 4.
okay so this is saying if n goes to
n and n plus 1 mod 2 that means
that any that means we can always go
from 0 to 1 and back again so that means
we can have a connected object
so i think what we should do is plot
this together with
the corresponding
nest graph
okay so hold on let me do this um
so i want to plot uh
let's plot the combination let's say
nest graph
um
this thing here a n and plus b
we want to do that okay let's do this
and function that
and then we want to say start from zero
and go
let's say five steps
and now what we should see here
okay let's try this all right so this is
showing let's go more than five steps
let's go
tens to ten steps there
all right what is this showing us
so this i think
when this is a connected graph
that is when things can rejoin again
oh boy well so much for that theory look
at this case here
this is saying basically we're starting
with zero
and so this is saying that we can only
reach even numbers
in this picture that makes sense because
we're starting
sorry numbers that are equal to zero or
two mod four
that make sense to people we start from
zero we start for a number that is zero
mod
mod four and so we wind up generating
going to two mod four but nothing else
we can't get to one mod four in this
case
make sense to people yeah
the um yeah yes
so my question then is um what is the
criterion
given that this is n goes to how do we
work out just by looking at those
numbers
a and b how do we work out what the
structure of this this graph is going to
be
is that some simple number theoretic
question
so that graph is telling us as we look
at
it's remarkably diverse actually that
graph
i have an urge to try just a few more
cases here
um let's go up to
let's say let's just go up to four for
each of these
whatever it's going to generate a bunch
of pictures and i probably should have
done a parallel table there
um
okay all right so this is
boy they all look the same
my other ones where are the ones that
just look like ordinary trees
so i mean something like this we're
starting from zero
and we can't get to one and 3
but we can get it can we circulate
around there
this is kind of showing us a map of
what values we can get to now in a case
like this i'm i'm
i'm very confused because this is saying
that starting with 0
mod 3 that's saying that that
0 mod 3 maps only to 0 mod 3.
so how can that be so n goes to 4n so
let's take that case as an example okay
so um
uh but did i have some place to put this
well um oh here
uh um are you initializing at zero
uh yes uh well well then you've got four
n so you'll only ever
reach evens and three plus ends so
you'll only ever reach
mods of three or the same mods as three
so excellent
yes i think wait a minute so well let's
let's check that so let's
um okay so i was gonna i was wondering
if we initialized something other than
zero
we will probably get a more interesting
result all right let's try
let's try rerunning this whole thing
initializing at one
because that may produce generally more
interesting answers
all right so where were we initializing
anything there
it is by the way always remarkable that
you can have a system like this that
looks so
simple and yet it can be a bit
non-trivial to
analyze what's going on okay
so let's see where was that case
still looks very much the same maybe
it's obvious that it has to be the same
so in this this case here was that our
case here 4n 3 plus n
oh yeah but once it's at 1 4 n three
plus n okay
let's just do it and label it okay four
n
three plus n
and it's probably going to be obvious um
okay how obvious is this
not as obvious as one might like all
right let's say we label it
with um
the the labels mod n
that might make it more obvious what's
going on so let's say
with g equals that graph
um
graph g and then we'll say vertex labels
arrow and now we want to name these
vertexes
vertex labels so we say vertex list
of g and then we want to say thread
i think well actually one way we could
do it let's just say
hash goes to mod hash
comma three
all right let's see if this works
um
okay very trivially this is saying
mod 3 everything is equal to 1 mod 3.
is that totally obvious
if you start off with okay so n
plus three is going to preserve the same
modulus
is 4n does 4n always preserve the same
modulus so if you have something
if i have something of the form three u
plus
v and i then say
times four times that right
um expand that out
12u plus 4v and so oh that mod 3
is always equal to
0 oh yes
zero why is it plus one why is for 4v
i guess we just make a table of mod
this is completely obvious i suspect but
let me just
be stupid and and do it explicitly
no it's not so completely obvious what
why is that plus one
because the v
see what has to happen is that
it we know it started as a plus one
but this is preserving it as plus one
for some reason
and so anything of the form three n plus
one
if multiplied by four um
that's just a table three u plus one
u goes up to ten and then let's say
four times that and we say that
mod 3 and apparently the answer is
always going to be 1.
and it is and there's probably an
extremely elementary proof of that fact
who can see that proof
oh because four is equal to three mod to
one mod three
i think that's why that's the case
but okay so what we're seeing here is
that
i mean i'm a little bit surprised that
we're not seeing because i thought that
up here
we saw cases two n plus one
two n plus three why are we not seeing
oh i see because we didn't have this a
multiplier here
we didn't look at the cases where there
was a multiplier here that's why we're
not seeing these other
these other things let me just look at
that case here
well let's just do the same exact thing
let's just compute the same
because that was a nice diversity of
different behaviors so let's compute the
exact same thing
and let's make that include
framed of this thing here
um
and that was equal to ic so the question
is what value of k
should we be using here what value of
the modulus should we use
because that's not determined by these
coefficients abcd
for making sense right so we could try
for example let's try doing mod let's
try doing
with k equals three for example
let's see what that picture looks like
okay so with k equals three we're not
really seeing anything particularly
notable i mean these are just
this is showing us things about what
modularly we can reach but i'm not sure
why we care about that let's try
k equals two um that will be the even
odd question for these things
okay what on earth do we learn from this
i mean that just doesn't seem really
they don't this doesn't seem to giving
us any information i mean it's not
showing us
why this one for example
is is different from this one
hmm well so
the question is can we figure out why is
2 n plus 1 3 n plus 2
a grid but yet 2 n plus 1 3 n plus 3
is a tree right what is the criterion
for when those branches rejoin
see what i'm saying so that that's the
question here two n plus one
three and plus two
that one makes a grid
but yet the one right next to it
makes tree
right so this one here makes a nice grid
yet
oh that's so weird i just changed that
to
that and i'm getting essentially a tree
why
so i had thought maybe this modular
arithmetic thing would give us an answer
because it might tell us why
these things can't ever rejoin but that
appears not to be the case
so who's got an idea for what might be
going on here
two and plus two contrast the
three n plus one and three n plus two
i think we have a 2m plus 2 case here
um we can try that in this case here
come now everybody we've got a bunch of
bright people here somebody's got to be
able just because i can't figure this
out doesn't mean nobody else can figure
this out
um ed do you have an idea
i'm looking at something with complex
you are really bright though that's not
what i need to hear that's that's that's
it's um barbara just
pasted in a chat as well yes
two on plus two
all right 2n plus what are you
suggesting you're suggesting just
just you can just say what you're
suggesting
3x2
oh you mean 2 n plus 2 that this case
for 2 n plus 2 okay let's check and try
that
that gives that and then the case for
3 n plus 2 so the question is whether
two n plus two gives the same
three n plus two no
no two n plus two again breaks that grid
well at least i feel better that i
couldn't figure this out instantly
but i'm disappointed that we can't get
this um
it's a nice candidate for more
simulation i think though
yeah yeah i mean what emerges through
different
configurations right i mean look i think
the point here
i mean the thing is
to me this i'm surprised that this isn't
a a case where one can use number theory
basically
to solve it um i'm surprised that this
gets
i you know i'm always surprised by this
is my the computational animals are
always smarter than you are type thing
this is um this is already something
that's producing
pretty complicated behavior um
but i'd also like to know like even in
this case right in this case
the question would be
does it i mean let's go to 10
steps is it going to make
just look at that thing look at that
thing i mean is it going to make a tree
or are there going to be branches that
join even after long periods of time
so for example here if i say layered
graph plot
um
of that with an aspect ratio of a half
let's say okay so what we're seeing
there
it's mostly a tree but it has these few
connections these are sort of some
few number theoretic random number
theoretic uh
coincidences presumably
and the question is you know is this
so what must be happening is in some
cases those number theoretic
coincidences
are frequent enough that the thing just
makes a grid in other cases they're
really not able to withstand
the treeing of the thing
let's see nick
is saying compare these all right we'll
try that
compare expand two times
three n plus one um
yes so so this rule where this is agreed
and the second one
is not
yeah that's you're saying you're saying
if you iterate the rule
once or what are you saying if you yeah
if you try to substitute one
rule instead of another you you
like get see more thing right
independent of each order you do
so we get five plus six independent of
the order
so we get a simple rule i see
and for the second one you know right
okay fair enough yes i had okay so in
fact i had looked at that a little bit
someplace here i had this notion of
index
index identities right where so what
you're saying is that
f two f one f two f one et cetera et
cetera et cetera
in one case f1 and f2 commute in the
other case they do not
that they're um
okay so maybe what we're seeing here we
could think about
this in terms of some commutator and
some
failure to commute so you're saying in
this case here
those two rules so you're saying if i
say
um if i ask the question if i say
f1 equals two hash plus one
and f2 well let's see what's the best
way to do this i'm
um i mean we can literally just
okay let's do it this way so we can say
um
[Music]
that's n so we literally just put this
in there
yeah if you if you just treat both of
both pieces of this prayer like a
functions you just
make a exactly
okay let's do that let's do that let's
write that as
um
commutator of let's say
f1 f2 and
ah by just a little bit messy with that
n there
um
well okay let's do this let's do this
let's take the commutation of the whole
function
f and let's say let's assume that that
function
f has so what we're going to do
we're going to apply it to some variable
x
so f of x will give two results
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to say
first of dad yeah first of this
that will give us the first one and
that's and then we want to take
that um and then we want to say
f of that and we want to take
this the second element of that
and we want to compare that with the
commutator the other way around
okay so let's take this now
okay and now we want to just say full
simplify of that
and as predicted that gives that okay so
now let's look at this commutator here
nice okay all right we're getting
somewhere
um
okay well probably we don't want full
simplified we might just want to expand
here
okay
but now what must happen what must be
happening is
for these there are identities so this
is asking to get a grid you have to have
the commutator vanishing
this case is sum f12221
or something equals f212 whatever it is
every time these things merge that's
essentially an index identity
if that makes sense
so now the question is can we compute
when there is an index identity so in
other words given these two functions
uh because not guaranteed that it's the
a fixed number of that the
number of indices going one one way is
the same as the number of indices going
the other way but the question is
how common is it i mean this reminds me
a little bit of number theory of those
things like uh what is it the is that
the abc conjecture is that some other
thing where you're asking
um
like in number theory you you might ask
the question
when is uh 2 to the n
equal to ed do you know what i'm talking
about
uh yes for example one example is 2 to
the third
plus one equals three to the three
squared
two to the third what to the third plus
one equals three squared eight eight
equals nine
and the question is when are powers
close together or
at a difference which is also a power
especially high powers right
so is that related to this do you think
it looks don't
i don't think so especially but it's
weird when coincidences happen
in number theory which is basically
another aspect of the abc
conjecture right but i mean this is
basically asking for coincidences
this thing here where this joins is a
coincidence
uh yes but with addition those can be
expected
this isn't addition it's got
multiplication in it oh um
look this is multiplication and addition
it's still
linear though it's it's when you get to
the higher powers uh like
for mod well okay if it's expected ed
tell me when it happens
oh well that's coal ants no it's not
because this doesn't have a choice
function uh
you're still asking for the complete
behavior um
uh if you do collats without choice you
run into the same problem
okay let's see that so what is collats
without choice
um two to two ends uh
three oh i
my dog
is that i don't think that's right
because it's not 2n it's n over 2.
um stephen did you see the chat from
phil
i did i think he's doing the same thing
we were just doing
actually
yeah he's doing the same thing we were
just doing
um
so ed ed may have been eaten by his dog
there's a lot of people in our local
neighborhood setting off
fireworks so if his dog's anything like
mine they're they're not happy right
right right he's setting off fireworks
because they have nothing better to do
what is this what what okay
okay so what is this showing us
ed what is this and what's that sequence
weirdness doing
add
i don't understand this at all i don't
understand what this is doing
what is that
posted something else to chat basically
could you explain what this is please
it's basically the reverse collage
conjecture starting with one what values
what integers do you reach
and basically let's understand this
let's understand exactly what you have
here okay because it's very similar
to what we're looking at but let's
understand exactly what this is
okay what is that sequence at thing
doing
oh that's just if um if it's not an
integer throw it away
that makes it much uh it lets you go a
lot further
i'm sorry i'm totally confused here this
is why don't we just say nothing instead
of that weird weird thing there
right if i'm not mistaken i wouldn't go
30 steps with that
okay that works
okay so let's expl let's understand
exactly what this is ed
okay so this is saying given
i mean this is an interesting object and
it's interesting how similar it is to
what we've got here
right but i want to understand it very
precisely
so if i were to write this out in terms
of a mod
function instead of the integer q right
what would it look like
did you understand what i'm saying so in
other words i say here
rather than if integer q n minus 1 over
3
i just say n
how do i get this this is this is
n minus
do you understand what i'm asking
i and you can definitely use mod instead
i'm not sure what it'll do
well i'm trying to get a simpler form of
this so that we can understand the more
general case
well for for collats you basically need
this form no no you don't collapse has
two choices it has a
even and an odd case right uh right but
right but uh if you want to avoid if you
want to see everything but avoid
fractions you need to throw out the
fractions
i understand that so we can throw that
out by looking at
n mod um
okay so you're saying mod
the mod is equal to one so this is just
saying here
the only point here i mean that that's
not getting us very far but that's
getting us somewhere right
so that's the case you're saying that's
equivalent to this
right right okay so now let's simplify
it further right
because what i'm trying to do is i'm
trying to write this expression
in terms of not
um let's see n minus one over three
think about this
so this is saying for any n
double it
if n is equal to one mod three
if it's equal to yeah what are the
simpler cases of this
that's what i'm trying to understand
because this is you're saying
okay so if i take
this is the colette's problem going to
what going to one
or what starting with one and seeing
what numbers it hits
no no no it's not starting whether it's
ending with one
right no the for for the reverse you
basically
start with one and then try the
operations in reverse i i know i know i
know but that means the collats problem
is ending with one right these are this
is yes
okay so this is so if i label these
okay so this is saying so there's
normally a cycle
right this is the cycle for the end of
the collapse problem right
right what is that cycle that cycle goes
one
for two is that right correct and
zero is an absorbing state correct
okay so this is saying that
13 would lead directly to four
how can that be uh the opposite um
you re for th for regular collets you
reverse it so
3 times 4 plus 1 is 13.
3n plus 1. yeah i understand that but so
so what are you saying here you're
saying that
that but normally everything attracts
down to so if we do the regular collapse
thing okay
so how will we do that we would say uh
what would we do for
to get regular collats we would start
we'd say nest graph
of um
yeah you've got it um
uh if well if even q
n over f even q of n n over 2
otherwise 3m plus 1.
right and but now i want to do that as a
nest graph
because what i want to do is i want to
start from a whole bunch of values if
i'm not mistaken
is this the right thing to do
do you understand what i'm doing here
yes
uh right
oh i want to go more than four steps
okay this is the right thing i think i
want to go like 20 steps or something
okay so what this is showing
is how things evolve to
so i want to say here
so the claim here is that everything
evolves down
to it evolves through 10 down to the 142
cycle
right
yeah it's the same i write i right it is
because
because everything has reached right so
the collats
did you understand i mean this is uh-huh
yeah okay so now
that should be so your claim is that
it's the same as this picture but it
doesn't look the same as this picture
because this has a loop in it
and is that because i've reached larger
values here
so so the claim would be if i go to
larger values here
let's say i go to 100 here and i go
let's say 40 steps here
okay so this isn't enough right because
the the collats problem claims that
everything
evolves down to the um to the value
so let's say i go 400 steps here
right my reverse thing um isn't quite
the same because um
if you have a even value
you can still do three n plus one
okay well let's take a look so this is
this is the the main collapse thing so
this is a tree
representing so i don't know what that
this represents
a very long sequence necessary to get to
the origin
correct correct
so what we could do in this picture is
just for fun we could plot
for example in the y-coordinate or
something we could plot the actual
values
right so we can see the thing going up
and down
how will we do that here uh
extract out the edge list
uh i get maybe find path um
i'd go to oeis
and let's see
well let's look at what happens if we
just go i'm just curious if i go to 200
200 things here i see
so that i i didn't realize it was such a
stringy object
the the going to you know
going to the origin here right so in
other words it's saying
um now if i were to say right i mean
the 3m plus one problem is basically
saying that this is a connected object
correct correct
but the connectivity is a little bit
difficult to determine because
it's got such a long uh you know
let's try a thousand of these and let's
try let's say 2 000 steps here to make
sure we're not
messing something up here wow it's kind
of interesting have i seen this picture
before i don't know whether i've ever
seen this picture before
um okay so anyway that's the tree
of the forward collats problem right
now you're explaining to me the reverse
collapse tree
so this has no this is a pure
attractor everything is being attracted
down to this
uh four one zero four one two
cycle right correct okay
so let's understand so what you've got
up here is something different what is
what is this up here
right that one it isn't purely a choice
function
it you basically can can go different
ways with
with the value so you could either
multiply by two or divide by three and
and sometimes
it wouldn't be the normal uh colots
operation
okay so so wait a second so if we were
to do the forward version of this what
would it be
i actually don't know well let's look at
it and let's figure it out
so what you're saying is n goes to 2n
which is the analog of n over 2
except that that
i mean normally we would say if it's
even you divide by two
otherwise you do this operation here you
do the inverse of this operation here
so in other words the statement of the
collats problem
is the object is always connected
what is the analogous problem here
is it that there'll always be a loop
somehow or what
i don't know
uh one thing you can do though is if you
look at the collats graph you got later
uh
31 is a far away point so if you if you
find the path
from 1 to 31 you'll get one of these
long strings
okay well from 31 to 1 more accurately
right
okay so find
shortest path
in that graph
from 31 to 1.
oops
okay so that's a path that goes through
some high values
right okay
so somewhere in this picture so if i if
i would look at that
um
do i say path graph of this
is that right i think so yes
okay so that's the spine so to speak
that takes one from 31
presumably it's going there yeah that
looks right
actually five five days but to say we're
to say 142.
it'll look better if i say sub graph
a little bit better all right so that's
so that's
an example of a path presumably it goes
from that branch down there well i don't
actually know where the weather's
which direction it's in okay
fair enough all right so so what's the
analog
in this previous thing here
right so let's look at this one here
so we can look at okay we're comparing
basically this here
to this here right right
so 13 leads to four there
where's 13 here 13 is right there
and 13 in no way leads to four in this
picture
uh but
it should be there
what should be that oh
oh right right right it because um four
is even
you you divide by two in this case
though
it doesn't it doesn't matter uh it
always takes the the two choices anyway
so
even though four is even it's
multiplying by three and adding one so
this is a path that's not
taken by regular collods
okay so you're saying that the regular
collapse is a subset of these paths is
that correct right
okay what subset
basically just just like that uh we
would basically
if if uh if the
ending node is even we were to remove
that path
right ending node is even
well i don't understand this these oh if
oh if it's
going odd to even we would remove it
so you're saying for any edge if i get
an edge list
from this right you're saying if i take
the edge list for this
okay and what you want me to do uh
select those where the
first value
isn't odd even
what isn't odd what do you mean the
first value
the the so that the the so that it's not
the case that
both the first value is odd and the
second value is even
so in other words you're saying select
the case
where not and what is it in terms of exo
i don't know okay but so you're saying
it's this
right yes okay
and so now you say i make a graph out of
those
great okay what the heck is that
doesn't look like any of these so let's
take
look let's do this let's take reverse of
that
select this take that graph with vertex
labels
okay i don't understand this at all let
me take a look at it offline
okay it doesn't seem right but but the
main point you're making which is very
interesting point
is that the problem that we're trying to
solve namely
of whether of when
this this thing here 2n 3m plus 1
okay your claim is that the
coincidences there have something to do
with the collats problem
right yes okay i want you to figure out
what they have to do with the collats
problem because i'm
i mean in other words
in a sense what's happening is any given
and you know it's a it's a set of
two ends and you know it's a sequence
one two two two one one
one whatever just like in the standard
collapse problem
if i'm going down this path
i could color each edge here with
whether it's an even edge or an odd edge
oh i just realized something else this
is related to something else in nks
where you looked at the complexity of
integers and which ones could be built
out of things like
add one or multiply by two and you have
a
and you have a plot of the different
graphs
i'm not sure if i had the graphs
actually i i'm not sure i had these
graphs but
not these graphs but you had the
complexity of
of uh of say 17.
okay building building integers
from operations you know it's just
amazing how these these really simple
things end up just
spiraling into such complexity so
quickly
um okay so let's see i had systems based
on numbers i seem to remember that it
was in
my section on i don't remember where i
had this
it was in a note um
[Music]
that's the digit sequences
you know i happen to remember where it
was or what an earth i could look for in
the index
[Music]
um
reconstructing initial conditions the
three n plus one problem reversible
three n plus one system
that's kind of interesting because that
um
the fact that it's reversible suggests
doesn't that suggest that we should be
able to run it both ways
i would think so yeah
so this is the reverse
and that comes from that page you should
track down whoever wrote this book he
seems pretty sweet
who knows it's probably 25 years ago
this was done
um that particular page i should
probably more like 30 years ago
uh okay wait a minute where is this
thing
come on why did i have that
all notes for this section
where would i have had that that piece
about
um
i mean i i remember the sign just
completely forgotten where it is
[Music]
um
come on where is it
um help
i think maybe i i used bit x or maybe i
put that in the index
if we're lucky it will be in the index
and representing integers 916. good good
good
what a crazy place for that to be
crazy place
whoever wrote this book was just trying
to stuff random facts into the
notes in the book
okay so what this was let's take a look
at this
two a plus b minus one
oh wow you're right this is very
analogous
so this is a tree
what is this doing a plus b a times b
what is this doing
do people understand what this is about
this is making a tree
making all possible trees and then
evaluating the tree by saying that the
nodes of the tree
are given by this operation in terms of
a bunch of ones at the
at the at the um uh so for example
here i would be saying in a sense
um i'd be saying something like this i'd
be saying groupings
of table of a bunch of ones
let's say eight ones with a function
f with two arguments okay
and now the claim is that if that
function f
is uh for example
two times hash one
f goes to two times hash one
plus hash two minus one
that miraculously if i were to take
union of that
that i would get
oh i see the claim would be if i do that
for all values so let's say n there
table of that
let's just use this function
as the thing here
so the claim is that this going up to n
equals let's say five
so eventually i will get every number
that's the claim here that makes sense
right i don't know why it's true but but
i i claimed that
um why is that related
this is saying this is a tree let's
let's understand what this is
so this is a tree so this groupings
thing how do i display the groupings
thing as a tree
i guess what i do is i just say
expression tree of that
so this thing here
let's say i say five here
then if i say expression tree expression
graph
those are all the trees that correspond
to the
those possible expressions each one of
those trees can be evaluated
by putting a one at every node at every
leaf
and then using that combination function
to to sort of uh actually this is
interesting for studying combinators i
should look at this for studying
combinators
because this this is a way of mapping
any tree to a value basically
and two different trees might map to the
same value
but it's a way of mapping any tree to a
value
but i don't i don't see a direct
relation to this
all right well okay so look the main
main takeaway from this which i think is
interesting is the relationship to the
collats problem and you're sort of
convincing me that that i shouldn't be
as embarrassed as i was that i couldn't
figure out what's going on in this case
right because the the behavior of
of whether there's a certain loop just
with the simple collats
whether there's any others is is one of
the
hardest problems in mathematics
and it just doesn't i you know what's
really interesting though
is that usually in studying these kinds
of simple program type things
it's not easy to relate the hard
problems in that case to the hard
problems in traditional math
so if there's a relation here that's
really interesting
right i mean it's kind of a little bit
scary if there's a relation between
what is an incredibly trivial version of
this multi-way i mean
this multi-wave system based on numbers
is even simpler than strings which is
even simpler than hypergraphs
and so these questions about merging and
causal and variants and so on for
hypergraphs which is what we need
for understanding quantum mechanics and
so on the fact that it's hard to figure
out what's going on
even for the trivial case of numbers and
that that's related to
a you know a sort of high problem in
mathematics
gives us a sense of how difficult the
mathematics for the physics case are
likely to be
right if if we had an exact way of
figuring out how the mergings occur
then we could apply that to the collatz
problem and solve it
yeah well fair enough okay but but so
but maybe this is a generalization in
some way
of the collats problem is it
i i would say it's actually a harder
problem for figuring out exactly how
things merge
um when you've got these choices okay
what do you think of my modulus
idea oh i think it's a fine idea it's
it's what it doesn't
get anywhere i mean in other words it's
just telling us
that we can color these nodes i mean
maybe i should just do that
do that explicitly color the nodes by
the
by their value mod you know mod 3 or
something
but it may not be very useful
i mean this is saying
right that's an attempt to put order
into this
into this picture
but it's not really helping
um
okay
all right well let's look i can tell you
some other things i figured out here
um i just can't believe that this case
is already such a mess
okay this was an attempt to make an
actual collapse thing
if even q of n n over 2 otherwise three
n plus
one
okay that's the actual collats problem
if i'm not mistaken right ed
ed are you with with us
hello egg he's been sorry
yeah yeah i'm yeah you're right you're
right i was
looking at um
gl 3n and 2n
there is um something you were looking
at
four years ago
i believe but but ed
why is this here not the correct
generalization of three and plus
the correct three and plus one picture
this is saying n goes to if it's even
and over two otherwise
oh i see oh no no i just added an
arbitrary
just for good measure n plus one here
see what i'm saying right
now the other case that i had started to
look at
was
the case where you add a mod
yeah these cases here where you're
saying
um
okay so in this case what is the
relationship between this
okay so this is mod
something like this okay so that's again
another collapse-like
thing i think
or maybe not right that's adding
see and now i'm curious if i take this
mod
for different numbers a and b here
um let's see i wanted to say table
that a goes up to
five b goes up to a i think because i
don't need any there's no point in going
the other way around
oh my gosh look at these crazy creatures
okay that has 157 000 nodes
let me bring that down to 10 or
something
oh gosh look at this stuff it's just
crazy
look at that thing what is that thing
doing
you know i'm sorry it just reminds me
again of this mantra the
computational animals are always smarter
than you are
um and also these look bizarrely similar
oh i see there's a two mod whatever i
wonder what these look like
um
if i don't put the two in there if i
just say mod
what is that going to do what's this
going to do here
oh my gosh even that isn't trivial how
can that be not trivial
that's just bizarre
look at this thing what the heck is
going on there
so this is looking at the case where you
are saying
for every this is just linear except
with mods
so that's one two three four
um
two so that's saying let's go like 30
steps here
let's not go 30 steps
oh is that thing periodic i wonder
let's try going up to like seven or
something here
what is this doing what is this doing
okay so that's seven two
oh my gosh this is just so crazy
what else did you label those points
yeah i will
okay so i'm sure what happens if i go
further here
i mean it's making this weird snake is
the snake
and we can take a look at the
vertex list and see where it starts
or the if any values stay missing or if
it if it eventually hits everything
but do you think it's periodic if it
hits everything yes
eventually after the some frobenius like
uh value
okay but so so you're
okay so let's just do that up
that's not what i wanted um
that's not what i wanted either okay
there we go
okay um let's just say
um well it is sorted
and complement
range 125 that
that's plausibly that's plausibly
reaching over value because probably got
let's go up to 40 steps or something
that's really weird because that's not
that's not froubenius-like in the sense
there doesn't seem to be a bounded
a finite length of that
but there is okay
explain that weird number theoretical
thing
oh but no the 125 oh it's only going up
to 125 so we don't know how much it goes
you got what i'm saying right yeah try
like 300 or something
okay but so there are there are values
here
that we're just not reaching however
high we go oh um
let's do um something equals that vertex
list and then complement range
max and then the thing
okay wait a minute you're saying put
that above
so vertex list is that okay
and then what complement range max vv
vv
oh let's just do this for arbitrary
okay and now we can try that with
up to a larger value
okay what are those numbers ed i
don't know
[Music]
let's do differences on them
oh how fascinating four times seven
times two
is fourteen oh oh right um
the the tail it
will eventually hit everything but the
tail
um will miss some values because it's
it's not wrapping around correctly
so i don't think it'll hit everything
this is saying it doesn't hit everything
the numbers numbers mod 14
that's missing a bunch of numbers mod
14. oh all right those will be the only
ones missing in general it'll hit
everything except for those
uh i'm not worried about the tail the
tail i understand is going to go away
so it's got a frobenius like phenomenon
and then it hits everything
other than the other than the multiples
of 14 correct
and the multiples of 14 doesn't hit
because
yeah 14 modul
mod 14 some value it might be plus three
or something who knows
okay so your claim is if i do this
computation
for other values of a and b okay so
let's try this for a
b here
that if i do this thing for table of
that
with um a goes up to seven
b goes up to a i actually might have to
do parallel table just because it'll be
faster
it's the numbers that are equal to 7 mod
14
in that case okay
should i do differences in all these
cases
that looks suggestive look at that last
one
look at that last one is that periodic
yeah that is periodic
yeah those are periodic
okay so fortunately this creature was
not
a a completely unruly object
so this case here
is understandable and eventually hits
everything
but with some slight exceptions but the
question is is this analogous to the
collats case or not
i noticed that barbara put in the um in
the chat
the result of of conway's which is which
was actually
also there's a version of that in the
nks book actually
in um um
kind of an interesting version i think
um
that has to do with
uh this case here
i think it's this case here where where
i'm looking at
um simulating cellular automata and so
on with generalized
arithmetic sequences
why do i do that someplace here but yes
you can you can get
an arithmetic these arithmetic sequences
can be
undecided you can get universality
that's the main
point um
i have that i was sure i had that
someplace here
um right
but but yes that's absolutely correct
that you can have um
nope i don't look at this particular
section very often
for some reason this is one of these
sections where yes we proved that you
can get
you can emulate a cellular automata yeah
this i think this is the right case
oh yeah arithmetic sequence can only has
a register machine that is the right
case
that's the case that proves universality
for a simple
arithmetic system and actually i should
be reminded
of um that is a good point that that's i
mean that's a case where
[Music]
what is that showing
i mean we could do the analog of the
collats this is an interesting that's an
interesting idea
um universal
um arithmetic system
although i'm not sure that that's ugh
definitely not the right thing there
um
so in this system this is a
generalization of collats where
instead of
where we are giving mod 20
mod 30 we're giving
what to do for each value mod 30. so in
the case of collats
it's just mod 2 and we give the value
but here we're doing it mod 30 so we've
got lots of choices
um
oh gosh
right but i don't know what that's going
to look like actually because so this is
a case
what does it mean that what what does it
mean that we can get universality
i'm not sure it raises the question
what's the simplest universal
multi-way system or multi-way system of
numbers for instance
um okay
let's let's okay we should probably rap
fairly soon
i'm um but uh
we were looking at complex numbers and
we were making
i mean this was another thing we were
looking at here was this dimension thing
that surprised me a bit
um but now
uh you know on the complex number side
of things
um where was that
okay i got these things so but by the
way this way of plotting with
coordinates
is there a way to do that with just
ordinary integers by taking the mod
something or other
or in different bases or something is
there a natural way to do it just like
there's a natural way to do it for
complex numbers
is there a natural way to do it for uh
yes uh when we did that with
mod in the seven
case uh earlier on in the same notebook
yeah but what about in the case of i
mean if i were doing that
in um for the for like that two n plus
one
basically you could just use that same
code and pick any modulus you like
i i know but i mean what about this is
this gonna do anything interesting in
that case
it'll not look periodic other than that
i don't know
yeah i understand but but i mean it
doesn't have any particular significance
to pick up because in the complex number
case there's no modulus being picked
it's just the actual complex numbers
plotted in you know re m
well that's one of those good questions
i'm not sure anybody's ever tried that
so
it might be interesting for an unsolved
problem so who knows okay well let's do
it let's just do that
just for a second um
okay so let's say mod
mod is this mod it's really it's it's
quotient remainder plots
right
okay so let's see we had some code i
think i actually took
okay all right let's try this one two n
plus one
i predict this is not going to be
interesting but
what on earth is that
what on earth is that
let's get rid of the um vertex labels
okay
explain
let's try the mod
instead of seven like 20 or something
well actually why don't we try two to
begin with
totally boring okay you think we should
try why don't we try
i'm going to try 2 to the n
what the heck is that
all right let's try two to the two to
the five
okay let's run a few more steps
okay what is that
what is that those things look like
um the things from um
uh
just uh you know multiples
what is that that what is this what is
this what
does this mean
huh
well we can try some let's try some
other modularly
just just to see whether you're learning
a thing from that let's just try making
when in doubt try them all
um so let's try modulus k
and let's try that table let's do well
it's just a table
um k
goes up to 20 let's say
i would consider that fairly
unilluminating
yeah they all look crazy but that's what
kind of we were expecting
yes i wasn't expecting this to untangle
things is there any other decomposition
that might untangle things like for
example
a some kind of base decomposition or
something
i don't see it
um
i don't see it
all right let's have a quick look at
complex numbers and then we'll wrap up
um although you've now convinced me that
even though i thought this was going to
be a trivial problem
that was significantly harder than i
thought
right right
you know it is amazing that for 40 years
i can make the same mistake repeatedly
that every time i look at some new
system i think it's going to be easy
because i'm convinced that it just
couldn't possibly be
another example of the same phenomenon
that i've seen for 40
years oh well okay well i i had the same
uh
idea about the had rejecter nelson
problem and just
played around with um
square root of three uh square root of
uh 33
with uh variations of the moser spindle
and
put up a a big field of
points close together um and aubrey
degray said
let's try adding square root of seven to
that and he solved the hadridge or
nelson problem
i just needed to go a little bit further
and that would have been it
right so by the way you you are also
pointing out
that the same type of system that we've
got here
um
uh we've also got the algebraic number
case of the system
and we've got um we've got the the uh
the rational case which i don't think
will be terribly different
i mean in this case here if i were to
use algebraic numbers here
i think this will just be this will be a
big mess
oh for goodness sake how could that not
look any different
uh because uh square root of two
happens to have special properties um
certain um algebraic numbers if they're
related to the saw numbers
will will converge very nicely like the
plastic constant but
most other algebraic numbers same as the
square root of three here
that that also falls into that category
okay but i'm gonna put pie there if pie
looks the same
something oh well that's here that's
just uh oh that's just
multiples of of uh pie i i'm thinking
more
multiplication well you're saying that
an arbitrary
um okay that's an interesting idea from
nick though
okay you're saying that this is saying
that for an arbitrary c
the basically that c
is completely as interesting that this
is completely undetermined right the c
it doesn't matter at all right is that
obvious
it is when you're just looking at uh
some because it's
it's basically ax uh
uh our two x three x four x and so on
okay now when that's square root of two
though it
it blows itself up even though the
powers of square root of 2
will be the same so we do that plus 1
those are not they're never combining
even though the square root of 2
so to speak done twice should be two
times n
right uh you think you might get more if
you use minus one or something like that
uh and then one thing look there is some
merging there right uh-huh
but you're saying there's only merging
in a trivial case
uh no i'm saying that you'll get more
merging with uh person numbers
all right let me try a friendly person
number
what is a friendly person well well two
uh it's derivative
uh two it happens to be one and also the
golden ratio
and the plastic constant and this is
something i was trying earlier i wasn't
able to get it to work well well
here let me first of all let me just do
how do i do the simplify here
i probably uh root reduce at the at the
start
over the whole thing yeah
oh and these maybe give different
answers if i say root reduce here
yes
oh for goodness sake you know these
creatures are just
too complicated it's crazy
it's just crazy
okay that is not probably gonna do
anything in root reduction but this
will
it's just crazy okay so you're claiming
so like that creature there
not very interesting
okay so your claim is that if i use
something other than a person number
so for example here do you think i
wonder if this is causal invariant
let's find out
i wonder whether the um
let's see starting from zero four steps
causal invariant queue
oh this is so weird
this is so weird okay let's try a
different number there
let's try something that isn't one of
your friendly person numbers square root
of 93
square root of 93 or some other can we
try a smaller one
17.
really can we try and a smaller number
that is um
oh sure that may take it no
that would be so weird if there's a
number theoretic connection
to causal and variance which is what
this is saying
uh square root of five i think will
behave differently though
i think that should work yeah but if you
use
um golden ratios there though i think
it'll be different
what the heck is that
what did i do here
[Music]
what on earth is that
uh confused we are here
i don't see anything wrong there well
that's i suspect that's a bug in the
multi-wave function system code
because i think if we just do nest graph
here
that's fine and dandy but so this okay
so let's just look qualitatively at what
it's doing
see that i bet that that thing is
causing varying because i bet what's
going to happen there if i say layered
graph plot
so what is the distinction between a
person
yeah i bet that's called invariant
so if we look at the corresponding
result
for square root of five
that's really cool yeah that thing is
much less
that thing is is i mean it still has
some cross connections but there they're
many fewer
right and that's just a a guess on my
part but uh
geometrically the poisson numbers behave
much more nicely than all others
and that's why i was able to find all
those results entitling that no one
found before
well but but i mean that's with respect
to
yeah but so i wonder whether this is
somehow related
those numbers have various properties
with respect to their powers yes
yes like the the um they have small
polynomial
they satisfy small polynomial relations
right and if you if you basically
multiply them and combine them together
in basic ways you wind up
hitting the same values um over and over
um which is very valuable in tiling
problems because
basically you want things to act in a
semi-predictable way
but not too predictable uh
that that's why these are make really
crazy tilings
all right well that's interesting as
well boy you know i thought this was
going to be like
a totally elementary note that was just
going to have some trivial
features no no one thing we haven't hit
on yet is
uh unique factorization domains yeah i'm
wondering if if there's something if we
append like the square root of five
uh and there there you have uh one plus
square root of five one minus square
root of five
times equals six um yeah i understand
that
ufd's corresponding things for various
algebraic extensions right so i'm
wondering if there's a nest graph with
two forks we can set up that will have a
node that has
four items coming in
because all the domains we've looked at
so far
have had unique factorization domains
i'm wondering if there's a way of
skewing things in square root of five so
that
it doesn't happen wait a second
and i i was looking at that earlier and
i couldn't find a case that worked well
but i believe one will exist
well you're saying if i were to look at
this
with i don't even know which the unique
factorization domains are but if you're
saying
with not with multiplication or with
multiplication
with multiplication uh for example in
the
domain um q square root of five
there's two ways of factoring six
okay but so if i say one plus square
root of five
times n and what are you suggesting
uh two but i tried this two times n
well let's try one minus square root of
five or
square root of five minus one oh well
you basically you'd want to have
uh you'd to set up both multiplications
to be possible
so the other one would be 2n
and basically if if if you hit 3
you would hit 6 with the 2n branch
and if you hit um one minus square root
of five you'd hit it with the other
branch
you know one of the principles of the
animals are always smarter than you are
is any attempt to construct something
will fail
right and i i did spend about 20 minutes
trying to construct this uh
to get that to work i'm pretty i'm
pretty sure there is something weird
in when you go outside of unique
factorization domains
well i don't quite understand why
um yeah that's just a grid it's just a
three-dimensional grid
um okay well look
the i think we should probably wrap up
here but the complex number case
the thing of interest there
okay so so with with real numbers here
is there a way of getting the leaves to
eventually converge
see what i'm asking
of getting the values to eventually
converge in other words
you're going to have essentially the sum
of some geometric series for example
what you want is the sum of two
generalized geometric series because you
can think of it
you know an arithmetic series i mean so
so a way to think about this
is like you know these are kind of
like arithmetic series
or geometric series so like this one
that we've been looking at is a
combination arithmetic series geometric
series
oh for that first nest graph there it
should be one plus
square i square root of five
well that's a whole different kind of
worms
yeah i don't know what that's gonna do
all right but you understand my question
ed that this is for the case where
it's going to be real numbers here right
the question is
well i see i see so the the issue is
there could be an
infinite even for real numbers if they
are finitely specified real numbers
algebraic numbers for example there
could be
places where they agree but if you have
arbitrary real numbers that cannot
happen
am i am i right right right even though
in the case of the complex
trees
i think it can happen i think it's what
bernat is
looking at where he's basically saying
there's an
index identity you see what i'm saying
it doesn't matter what the
values are right i think israel are
related to special values in julia sets
yeah i'm just going to look at this one
thing that that
nick had sent us here i don't even know
what this is it's just spectral
decomposition i don't even know what
that is
um
uh see what it is
what is this creature
what is this
seven and mod
i have no idea what this is
i'm guessing in
z5 6 would have
two different decompositions
everything seems to have two different
decompositions
okay i have no idea what it's doing
well we need to a base for the thing so
we need to know
there is a function integer spectral
basis
you can look in the properties there
uh property situations there is
an example of how to
spectral basis but that doesn't look
like a short
exploration
it looks like an interesting thing but
we can just run it for this case let's
just
just try it you have an idea what
what the base should be here so this
would be instrument spectral
decomposition
lag
shouldn't be a prank because it's going
to be just one coordinate
no it's this is going to give a pair of
coordinates right for every number
n that's going to give a pair of
coordinates
even more than two can give more than
two
it depends on on your basis or basis
integer
it's gonna blow up then for some values
here
okay so those are probably the cases
where it fails where it gives more than
two values
so in those ones we would have to plot
it like in three dimensions or something
yeah well that's kind of interesting i
don't know what this is doing
the is this your function
the yeah it doesn't mind good
okay then you can explain to us what it
does at some point
the um
hmm okay well that might be doing
something interesting here it's hard to
tell
i mean it's some
very hard to tell
ah i see that's two steps
i may also be the case that many
values are going are being mapped to the
same positions which means that this
looks simpler than it really is because
the thing is really tracing
a bunch of different paths all right
well we should wrap it up here
um and uh
well ed has convinced me that this is a
more complicated problem than i thought
but we should not give up and i want to
produce this bulletin to at least
explain what um
uh um
one note you basically need to say is
collapse is difficult
yes but ed i want to see the exact
correspondence
all right let's wrap it up thanks a lot
guys and uh
see y'all tomorrow okay thanks
bye everyone goodbye thanks bye thanks